foreign
challenge to America's Auto industry is
coming from China the number of Chinese
Auto exports jumped by more than half
over the past two years it has joined
Japan Germany and the us as one of the
world's top vehicle exporters Elizabeth
Palmer shows us how we could soon get a
chance to drive a vehicle made in China
shanghai's First Auto Show since the end
of zero covid offered a glimpse of the
future
almost every car here was either hybrid
or electric from Chinese startups to
establish players like byd one of the
largest ev makers in the world to Legacy
American brands the test drives were
virtual over the past five years China's
Automotive exports have more than
tripled
until now they've mostly gone to
developing countries but that's changing
Julie the Chinese company that owns
Volvo has the US in its sites with a
whole new concept and brand link Ally
viser is its CEO let's sell almost like
a Netflix of the car industry a monthly
subscription for a flat fee of about 600
a month which covers maintenance and
insurance
drivers can lease a link car and back
out anytime
and the link app lets drivers share
their vehicles when they're not using
them for cash back we have now some
customers in Europe who actually gain
more on sharing than they pay their
monthly fees it's a bold initiative
especially now given the frosty state of
chinese-american relations are you
fighting anti-chinese Prejudice in the
states are you anticipating that being a
factor by the time you get going yeah
absolutely but he's confident consumers
will buy in Chinese owned or not the
real concern is politics I think what
worries are more is is the political
movement that may happen in terms of
import barriers Etc the U.S is one of
the toughest car markets in the world
and now two things appear certain the
road ahead is electric and the Chinese
are coming up fast in the rear view
mirror
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Tokyo